hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
at the beginning of section four of
david hume's inquiry concerning human
understanding he
introduces a distinction that will not
only be very important
in this work but run throughout pretty
much
all of hume's works as
a general distinction whether he's
making use of it or not
so it's really important to understand
it and
and get it down because it's sort of a
key that helps you understand
the reasoning taking place for example
in his dialogues concerning natural
religion or or in other works as well
and it's a very simple distinction to
wrap your head around once we go through
it a little bit
it's a distinction that he brings up at
the start by saying
all the objects of human reason or
inquiry
may naturally be divided into two kinds
namely relations of ideas
and matters of fact now objects of human
reason or inquiry anything
that we could be interested in
anything that we could be curious about
anything
that we could take a position on so
don't let the reference to reason
throw you off the inquiry part is in
some respect more important
when we're deciding what we're going to
order from a menu
at a restaurant we are engaged in a kind
of
inquiry what what am i hungry for you
know
is this worth the money that i'm gonna
pay for this this one says
you know uh instead of a price it says
the market price
i wonder what that could be you know for
the lobster that i'm gonna pick or
something along those lines that is
inquiry uh
thinking about uh should i date this
person
or not date this person should i ask
them out or shouldn't i ask
that is an inquiry all sorts of things
fall within the scope of inquiry
so you know it could also be like i get
out of bed and
i don't feel good what's going on am i
sick
did i not get enough sleep did i
drink too much the night before is it
some environmental factor that is an
inquiry as well so
anything that we would engage in
reasoning about
in a very explicit way or anything that
we're wondering about
figures into this and he tells us we can
divide these up
into these these two classes so let's
look at relations of ideas
first what does he tell us geometry
and mathematics now he speaks about
algebra and arithmetic
you know mathematics was not quite as
advanced of course they did have the
integral calculus at that time
going beyond algebra but hume is not a
particularly mathematically oriented
thinker and he thinks that you'll get
the general idea
when you took mathematics classes what
was it
that was so distinctive about math you
might say well they were
right answers and wrong answers and that
was what was really great about it
compared to say social studies or
english science of course is supposed to
yield us
you know the right answers and the wrong
answers but it works when we talk about
the sciences
and we're comparing them to mathematics
we're actually talking about say the
natural sciences
which have some empirical aspects to
them as a matter of fact
they're entirely shot through with a
kind of
empirical data orientation whereas
geometry
mathematics not quite so much and you
might say wait a second i remember my
geometry class
and we had these protractors and we had
to spin them around and make circles and
you know bisect angles and all that sort
of stuff yes that's true
you were carrying out a crude
approximation
of what real geometry is which is
something purely of ideas
geometry you know is carried out by ways
of proofs and you could do it as he says
even if no triangles and circles existed
in the world
you could still do geometry same thing
with mathematics
you know the relations between numbers
have a different sort of
certainty and you know you could say
tractability to reasoning
than experiential things do even the
things of the sciences
so they provide a prime example there he
could have added one other thing
logic logic so long as it's deductive
logic
and even if you think about this maybe
the structure of inductive logic on a on
a meta level
is certain demonstrable it's
it's what hume is calling relations of
ideas
and he tells us that within relations of
ideas
every affirmation is either intuitively
or demonstrably certain either we begin
from it
as an axiom and we say that well we just
know this to be the case
how do we know it to be the case we just
know it and that's it that's a starting
point
or we reason from those starting points
or from other theorems that we've
derived at some
some place along the line you know the
apparatus of logic we don't have to keep
proving you know how say truth tables
work to know that they work
they can be demonstrably certain
he tells us that a little bit later
these involve
abstract reasoning uh priori now this ah
priori term
is one that you're gonna see quite a bit
in hume
by the time that he's you know talking
about these things a priori has become
part of the philosophical lexicon
and what does it mean no experience is
needed as a matter of fact you're
actually better off without any
experience
to get in the way of carrying out these
these inferences
by working with relations of ideas you
could say in a certain respect that
relations of ideas
are things that are entirely in your
head
uh without any engagement with the
outside
world that's a little bit of a
misleading way to think about it you
could
equally say they exist entirely on paper
or whatever it happens to be whatever
model or metaphor you want to use
they have no actual connection with the
world
of our experience doesn't mean they
can't be applied
you can apply geometry to you know
architecture
you can apply mathematics to
you know thinking about how chemical
interactions ought to work
but you don't need any of that other
messy
empirical stuff as a matter of fact when
you're carrying out these reasonings
you're better off without it
on the other side we have matters of
fact
what hume is going to call
are you know engagement with with uh
moral philosophy moral understood quite
broadly and moral propositions
anything that has to do with the reality
of things
anything that has to do with our
experience of the world
and so it includes everything else so to
go back to our examples
about should i ask this person out on a
date
and then you might add the you know
subsequent
question well how should i ask them out
on a date what words
should i use in order to try to
achieve the effect that i want to do or
create the opening
for the other person to produce effects
that i i would like we want to just kind
of rather human
language right not very romantic but if
we're doing that we're actually
inquiring about matters of fact and this
is this is actually where a lot of
people get things screwed up
they treat things like dating or
cuisine or you know exercise
as if they're merely about relations of
ideas and they deductively
opine about all sorts of stuff and
they're usually full of it
they they are quite unsuccessful because
they don't actually connect it to
experience or when they do they connect
it to too little experience that they
generalized too much from
so anyway everything else and he says
that the evidence of the truth
of these other things may be very very
strong
for example he uses the sun will rise
tomorrow
right none of you doubt that but
it's not a hundred percent the sun could
go out
and we have science fiction things where
that happens right um
there's actually a movie recently where
the sun darkens
didn't turn out to be a very good movie
i actually had to quit it
about two-thirds of the way through
because nothing was happening
but the fact that you can conceive of
that means that it's not a hundred
percent
the evidence of the truth is less than
relations of ideas because this is what
we call a posteriori it's not
a priori it's no longer purely deductive
although deductive reasoning may play a
part in it
it is either inductive or abductive or
whatever other model we want to use and
contrast against that and that's that's
a little bit of a side note
that i don't want to get too bogged down
in hugh makes a couple really
interesting
and important points here which again
he's going to use
later on in other works
so the contrary of a matter of fact is
conceivable
it's not something that couldn't
possibly
be the case right he says the contrary
of every matter of fact is still
possible because it can never imply a
contradiction
and is conceived by the mind with the
same facility and distinctness
as if ever so conformable to reality
that the sun will not rise tomorrow is
no less intelligible a proposition
and implies no more contradiction than
the affirmation that it will rise right
we can't imagine
what it would be like for the sun not to
rise now you said well what about people
who
have a really truncated imagination
you know hume isn't going to talk about
those here but that that would be a
problem
not for him but for them they would
think all sorts of things are actually
relations of ideas that are matters of
fact
and this is a very interesting
point hume thinks that because
we can conceive of things being
different than they are
we can never be a hundred percent
certain that they're going to turn out
the way that we
expect and you know in in large respect
that's quite right
whether it's 100 percent well that's
that's an issue that we could
talk about later on and whether that and
the workings of that falls into
relations of ideas
that's another another conversation for
another time
but we will say this this
is quite interesting so contradiction
right you could say well wait a second
the sun not rising contradicts things
that we know about the sun
namely that we're not seeing any reason
why it should
stop you know rising or actually just
emitting its light
and and the earth you know spinning and
stuff like that you said well okay so
you're saying that there's a
contradiction there but it's just a
contradiction for another
matter of fact which could also be wrong
which could also be false it's not
contradicting any sort of
relation of ideas so the way in which
contradiction is working here is quite
important he also says that
these matters of fact involve reasoning
from other things you know from the
basis of what it is that we
sense or remember or imagine we have to
have
some sort of contact either with the
outside world or the interior world of
our own perception
and our body well we can have all sorts
of
matters of fact about what hume calls
the passions
you know i get angry when this happens
um you know for example one of the
things that tends to gall me
is when fabrics stick to each other in
such a way as to kind of get in my
way i'm trying to tie my tie and it's
not tying right because it's stuck
on the material of the shirt now that's
you know a
bit about my own personal psychology and
that doesn't have to be the way
it is and one example of how i know that
is other people don't get similarly
upset
right so maybe there's something about
my own characteristics and constitution
that leads to that but i don't even have
to be that way myself that is entirely
on the side of matter of fact
hume also tells us one really important
thing
about this side of matter of fact
he says that matters of fact the truth
of them
our belief in them is founded
if not exclusively but
primarily on the relation of cause and
effect he actually says
all reasonings concerned matter of fact
seem to be founded on the relation of
cause and effect
by means of that relation alone we can
go beyond the evidence of our memory and
senses
if you were to ask a man why he believes
any matter of fact which is absent for
instance that his friend is in the
country or in france
he would give you a reason and this
reason would be from some other fact as
a letter received from him
or the knowledge of his former
resolutions and
promises so when we're claiming things
about other matters of fact that go
beyond our direct
experience it's usually from some sort
of inference
based on cause and effect could also
involve
contiguity resemblance yes
but it's going to be based on some
connection to other matters of fact
oftentimes quite a few other matters of
fact
so this is the fundamental distinction
that he's making and he's going to do an
awful lot with this
you